there's a funny meme that uh someone
posted this on 4chan a long time ago
that any
any sufficiently free uh internet space
becomes right wing
and the left can only maintain the space
if they have hard moderation and
censorship
that seems to be the case if you if you
look at facebook
in spite of the censorship the top posts
are still daily wire
you know dan bindino fox news etc i
think that's right i think it's uh in
any period of history where you have
one uh one faction social faction
political faction whatever
trying to maintain an ideology based on
complete myth
which many of you know the assumptions
the assumptions of the
the uh cultural left are you know gender
is a social construct all of these
things
as soon as you have free speech that'll
be threatened and the most popular
people will be the people who challenge
that
the only the only way they they maintain
this in in popular
that's what cancer culture is you know
do you see what happened in san
francisco with that guy
the free speech rally got his teeth
punched think about how crazy it is that
this guy
decided to step up and say the
billionaires are bad so antifa shut up
and punched him in the face
yeah are they working for the
billionaires yeah calling him the n word
as well
yeah over and over again weird alliance
between the cultural left which used to
be the anti-establishment left
and the corporations the billionaires
and the neoconservatives
the neoconservative foreign policy think
tanks they're all aligned now
what is this you've got you've got the
the neocon never trumpers who ran full
speed the democrats after trump booted
him out
you've got antifa beating people up on
the behalf on behalf of them
a guy comes out and he's like yo it's
it's really bad that international
you know multinational billion dollar
corporations are restricting the rights
of the people
punched in the face joe biden is funded
by wall street
trump is winning on small donors biden
is winning on wall street donors and
bernie sanders is supporting joe biden
talk about backwards and insane the
billionaires in this country are
terrible destroying everything now go
for the guy funded by the billionaires
to be fair trump is a billionaire
himself so you know i guess it's still a
weird circumstance
it's very it's very strange i think the
most frustrating thing about
the the social justice warrior left the
antifa left the left that'll punch you
in the face is that
they pretend to be anti-establishment uh
they've been doing that for years but
actually they're
they found themselves in alliance with
elites and uh with corporations because
they're the only powers in society that
actually you know suppress the truth and
they knew the truth be surprised because
their entire ideology is based on
nonsense
it's so stupid none of it makes sense
antifa going out and hitting somebody
because he's complaining about
billionaires that's just weird to me
no no yeah i think they're being
manipulated by the powers because
they're not smart
i don't want to say they're stupid
because it's a broad generalization but
anyone that's on the street just
doing random street violence is pretty
dumb i think it's a dumb thing to do
yeah not a smart way to get your point
across these are the same people who
trashed seattle in 1999 in the trade
protest they were all about you know
ending the bad trade deals then along
comes a president who said i'm going to
end the bad trade deals and he does have
the bad trade deals
and now they're just beating up his
supporters in the street dude look at
bernie sanders
in 2015 seriously go back a lot a lot of
people might not remember this you go
back and you google search
bernie and trump and you'll find a bunch
of articles saying bernie and trump are
very similar
and there was a point where bernie had
to be like i'm not like him but a lot of
their core policies were the same
illegal immigration was bad bernie was
was uh fairly moderate on gun gun issues
when he said it was a rural versus urban
debate
because he's in vermont he's like we
don't have the same problems because
people in vermont like their guns
you had him saying the tpp the
trans-pacific partnership was a
was a problem and we've got it we got
what happened to that guy
all of a sudden now he's like the
billionaires but uh they're all funding
joe biden so go vote for him it's like
he immediately just said please let me
in the establishment
trump on the other hand kick the door in
you know you know an alliance between
the populist left and the populist right
is probably the thing that terrifies the
establishment the most
uh i i kind of think that's if you look
back through history there's always you
know new consensus
for new political consensus form to
replace the old ones the reagan
consensus the neoliberal consent has
replaced the fdr consensus
there's a new consensus waiting to
happen the populist left and the
populist right of forming the nucleus of
it
but it's being held back by this
establishment class that simply won't
let go
i think that uh was starting to happen
during occupy wall street
so the early days of occupy wall street
when i was down there i remember seeing
a really like a 60 year old man and
woman and they were sitting in chairs
with an american flag nobody complained
and they had it set up
and people were talking about it because
the core of what brought people
out was the big banks in wall street are
corrupting our system
it's revolving door politics the whole
thing is broken and you had
conservatives libertarians
and leftists who had shown up then
along came intersectionality identity
politics
the older people who could not live in
the park ended up leaving the younger
people
did and then these wealthy college
educated brooklynite kids with trust
funds not all of them but a handful of
them i know them personally they are
trust fund kids
started preaching intersectionality and
identity politics
and then all of a sudden you end up with
someone you know serena williams
who is a black woman worth tens of
millions of dollars and she's oppressed
and the homeless guy sitting in the
bridge is an oppressor because he's
white
what that did was it fractured any
possibility of the populist left and
right coming together
because now you've got aoc who is full
on board with overtly racist ideology
that is like it's it's it's freaky how
racist these people are
they're calling it anti-racism and then
literally saying but we should have
racial discrimination
yeah okay that's racism well no but we
are anti-because it's for good things i
don't care what you think it's for
it's funny because the ideology they
espouse
they're like racism is prejudice plus
power therefore
only white people can be racist
anti-racism is quite literally the same
thing
when it's four minorities and you
discriminate against specific minorities
and other racial groups for the benefit
of particular racial groups
it's like the same thing yeah well when
you say prejudice plus power who's more
powerful today than google
uh yeah the most racist people in the
world today are in silicon valley
they're programming the algorithms that
run our world
uh if you get the book read read the
part on machine learning fairness
machine learning fairness oh that's the
good sensor thing right
uh that's actually not the good sense
this is really something different
machine learning effect found is an
entire
entirely new field set up in
universities and it's being funded by
silicon valley and they have their own
machine learning fairness departments
now
the point is to bring computer science
and critical race theory together and
left-wing sociology and left-wing
feminism
they want the assumptions of those
left-wing fields to be embedded in
computer science
it's impossible it's it's it's it's
functionally impossible
well this is this is what i said in the
book right so an algorithm an unbiased
algorithm is just a machine for noticing
pattern it's a machine for analyzing
data
and uh pattern recognition noticing data
analyzing data is actually inherently
right-wing
because it busts political completely
correct narratives imagine if you
train a machine to look at crime data or
you train a machine to look at you know
the data of women going into certain
fields or certain educational fields
you know or you know train a machine to
who's who's more likely to commit a
terrorist attack around the world
um like that's going to spit out some
very politically incorrect conclusions
so this is why they created machine
learning venice to bias the algorithms
obviously they call it fairness it's the
opposite of that
so i guess theoretically they could put
weight in them
if this word emerges then apply it but i
i don't see it working you know you know
i did i did a segment on my second
channel talking about
the problem with wikipedia and critical
rate and critical theory
in general the the example i used is uh
transgender and so what the left just
started doing was pulling the clip out
of context to make it seem like i was
anti-trans here's what i actually said
if you go on wikipedia which is a very
formulaic and logic
based system granted it's subject to
manipulation and bias but the way it
works is very simple
present a source what does the source
say
include it cite it so you go to
wikipedia
and you have this web of all of these
different articles that interlink with
each other
go to woman in wikipedia what's it say
it says a woman is an adult human female
and then you click female and it says
barring you know certain abnormalities
irregularities
females are the members of the you know
species that produce ova et cetera et
cetera
and then if you go to male that perv
produce a sperm
and then it says man an adult human male
then go to trans woman on wikipedia
and it gives you this very different
definition
so it's it specifically says that uh
the point i'm trying to make is how do
you have the idea that a trans woman is
a woman but these two articles can't
connect to each other
right so if a woman is an adult human
female then a trans woman can't
you know according to wikipedia be a
woman because a woman produces ova so
it doesn't make sense the logic of the
system is is impeded by
the fracture the fracturing of what the
ideology represents
which is why so often you hear uh anti-w
types say
define woman because we can very easily
using a system
like wikipedia but in critical theory
you can't
so the point the point i'm getting to is
if this is why they have to invent the
rhetorical trick
you know gender and sex are two separate
things so you can you can still have the
biology but you also have this concept
of gender
but that's that's actually fine yeah the
problem is that when you have wikipedia
telling you
so okay what they need to do now is they
need to go in and they change change the
definition of what
woman is so that's why you get anti-cw
people saying define woman because
the official definition on google miriam
webster and in wikipedia is
adult human female what they should do
is make trans women one word
and have a completely different that's
offensive that's the problem that's the
problem with critical theory
so and again i'm not saying any of this
to say trans women are or are not i'm
pointing out the clash in the existing
system on wikipedia wikipedia
is not going to create some kind of
nebulous understanding of critical race
theory
or i'm sorry critical theory in general
intersectional left
when you go to them they will hold
contradictory views because they're
human beings but a computer
doesn't do that it can but you go on
there and you're like this makes no
sense these things don't
connect but they it's like how could how
could wikipedia say two different things
the exact same time
quantum computing i think i guess sure
yes both both exist at the same time us
define trans theory there you go perfect
what we're trying to do
with well there will be some
difficulties like that but at the end of
the day what these leftists are trying
to do is
every definition that these algorithms
are trained on everything they're
trained to recognize whether it's hate
speech or misinformation the people
doing the defining the people
training the algorithms how to recognize
those things will be left-wingers so
it'll always be their definition
there will be some cases where like
gender where the definition is very very
tricky for the reasons you mentioned but
there will be other cases where
the algorithm will only recognize the
left-wing definition of something is
this all stemming from liberal college
kids like zuckerberg
larry and sergey just being happened to
be the ones not coded
in the beginning no i don't think so i
i've had this conversation with uh with
peter pagosian
and and james lindsey and helen pluck
rose who did the so-called squared hoax
very very smart individuals and uh peter
production for instance
he believes and this is a while ago this
conversation so i don't you know maybe
his opinions changed
that the the intersectionality emerged
through the colleges and the 80s and all
the stuff
my argument was maybe but it only exists
today
because of the accident of the facebook
algorithm and so i i've mentioned this
several times but for for
for for you alm i'll tell it now and to
everyone listening basically what
happened is
in the early days of facebook they were
trying to figure out how to maximize
uh site longevity like how long someone
was on this on the website
and so they started creating feed
algorithms it was a combination of
factors in in the early days of facebook
you just got reverse chronological
feed right you followed somebody you
were friends if they post something you
got it
as the site grew bigger and bigger
people started following and liking more
and more pages you end up with someone
who on average had 300 friends but also
liked 300 pages and their feed was
so fast they couldn't read through it so
facebook said let's let's create an
algorithm to make sure we're showing
them what they most likely are to to
enjoy and click on what ended up
happening was
around the same time digital blogs
started popping up and it was partly
because of facebook they started making
money becoming successful
the articles were getting shared on
facebook facebook liked that because it
was creating activity on the platform
and then these companies like huffington
post etc started making money
but something interesting happens when
you when you incorporate
facebook constantly updating its
algorithm to work better and better and
better
we ended up getting waves of police
brutality videos there was a period
where there was one website that was
ranked
global top 400 or something when it was
nothing but police brutality videos why
because it was what people were clicking
on so facebook kept shoving it in
people's faces just beating them over
the head with it like
this is what you want and it was
shockingly crazy footage of cops just
beating people and beating people
so what happens is the news
organizations the blogs
that started writing shock content
started seeing more traffic and making
more money
eventually they learned wait a minute
there's more to life than just police
brutality
there's also racism and sexism right so
some articles some websites started
writing
racism racism some said sexism sexism
racism is x
sexism is why you get x views or y views
combine the two
and you get x plus y views
intersectional articles started getting
way more traffic
the racist sexist police police
brutality
targeting you know black people and boom
black lives matter pops into existence
so what happens is these news
organizations realized and whether was
on purpose or not
they made more money when they wrote
about all of these subjects combined
and now you actually see this stuff like
vice had one article that was really
funny that it was like
it was it was like black trans women of
color fighting back against police
brutality for black lives matter and
it's like they just jammed
every possible keyword in there because
facebook would then share it with more
communities they would get more traffic
and make more money
thus intersectionality was perfect for
this algorithm
it started to emerge because the
algorithm was trying to find
what you know people would want to see
the most here's what i add to that
i think you're right that is what
happened i remember that distinctly in
2013 2014
but i also remember that the uh the
backlash against that also did mad
traffic right so exactly it was sort of
naturally correct
if if they allowed it to happen it would
have naturally corrected itself no
because people would have got sick of it
they would have wanted some challenges
to the prevailing viewpoint
they did and it created the anti-sjw
movement
exactly but then they shut that down but
i mean sort of sort of
but it was just it was polarizing it was
creating two
tribes it was it was the the reaction
and and the and the opposite reaction
and so yes isn't that how politics has
always worked there it's always been
reaction and anti-reaction
i think what was happening on social
media was the things people wanted to
talk about
um that maybe the establishing class
didn't want to talk about they were sort
of out of touch by then
that that rose to the fore but it was
still a battle between two distinct
sides and i think
the anti-sgw side was actually winning
because they had the fact that the
arguments on their side
their continent was going just as viral
they uh they were the ones who got trump
elected
so if the social media companies hadn't
clamped down i think this would have
resolved itself naturally
i don't know if it would have resolved
itself i think uh i think we're still in
it
oh we're absolutely still in it but uh i
think it's being prolonged by internet
censorship if
if you took that uh control um control
off i think you just have a natural
contact between
two political factions and one of them
would win and that would be the
sjw site they're artificially
controlling it to help the sows
stay in power control the narrative even
though it's completely discredited well
so here's what ends up happening
when you get someone on the right who is
fringe and extreme and crazy or whatever
they get nuked immediately
just gone on the left however they're
allowed to keep doing it so that's what
i was mentioning earlier
you end up with two sides one where the
fringe elements of the right have been
purged and all that's left are
suit wearing you know milk toast vanilla
conservatives
who won't do anything about social media
censorship by the way seriously but but
but
the left is is have you seen this video
of the six
it's six videos of women in their cars
screaming at the top of their own oh
yeah have you seen the one where they
where they mash it all together
that's the one yeah yeah yeah so you
have these videos where these women are
like
no trouble they're screaming
i tell you this you take a milk toast
vanilla conservative
wearing a suit saying you know i just
think that you know
we should work hard and make money and
then you put that next to the women
screaming to have their lungs what's a
regular person going to think
it is backfiring in my opinion now
whether or not trump wins
you know is yet to be seen we got two
weeks and it will be
like i'll tell you this man banning uh
suspending the new york new york post
locking down their social media was such
an insanely desperate move the mask has
been ripped off there's no
more facade we know exactly what they're
doing and it might work
the fact that you have these women in
their car screaming like lunatics
it's because they're so heavy-handed in
their manipulation
that these people are trapped in a
paranoid and delusional reality
where trump is literally hitler and he's
taking kids and throwing them in cages
and they're freaking out panicking
because they see it all day non-stop
and they can't break out of this just
trap from from big tech
well i mean the liberals media model
since 2016 has been you know trump shot
content we're going to shoot everyone
with how evil and bad trump is
and that's what's leading to the
screaming uh women in their cars
um but i i will post back on the idea
that uh
only allowing the reasonable
conservatives to stay on social media is
somehow a help to the movement because
they're precisely the ones that are
least likely to push back on this
craziness
they're the most player just apologize
say oh you called me a racist i can
explain
10 reasons why i'm not a racist and
that's not convincing to people that's
not persuasive to people it just looks
weak and stupid
and you don't really challenge the
arguments so that's that's the downside
there
certainly for like elections it might be
a help because
voters undecided voters moderates will
just see the craziness of the left
and respond accordingly but ultimately i
think you know
if trump loses the election it will be
big tech that stole it and this is the
whole uh
thesis of the book when you start
manipulating search results on google
uh so that people you know it all comes
down to undecided voters so you might be
like a
heavy news consumer especially if you're
watching this show you're very clued up
on all the issues very hard to
manipulate you
but think about what an undecided voter
someone who doesn't follow politics
every day
is seeing when they go on to google to
find out about the two candidates it is
endlessly trump is evil trump is evil
and all day
every day that's the real thing yeah but
there was a story from time magazine
this woman went around the country and
found
nobody cared nobody cared that she would
go to these people and say here's a
headline say oh i don't care about that
and you know the way they wrote it was
all of these people believe
misinformation what do we do and it's
like you're in a bubble i don't care
the journalists are in you know it's
really funny it's like here's the way i
see it they're all in the ivory tower
and they're sitting in this room with
each other all laughing and sharing fake
news each other thinking they're in the
real world
and they're not regular people don't
like antifa
call them out they won't they don't it's
true
i mean that you can give these guys all
the advantages you want you can put all
their stuff at the top of google but if
it's bad stuff if it's bad propaganda
it's going to have the opposite
effect um i will try i will read one
extract to you from the book though
because
this just gets to the heart of how they
manipulate people and persuade people
do it if they can fight if i can find it
yeah man give me a minute i would hear
it
ah where is this so what what is this
this is their manipulating
of it's it's how they pinpoint people's
political beliefs and
uh yeah you were mentioning did you find
it right here we go
so this is a quote from a facebook
source the plan for polarization is to
get
people to move closer to the center we
have thousands of people
on the platform who have gone from far
right uh this is the way
facebook defines fire right by the way
not necessarily the way we define it
who have gone from far right to center
in the past year
so we can build a model from those
people and try to make everyone else on
the right follow the same path
um he goes on to explain how this would
work let's say everyone who goes from
far right to center watched video x
then maybe we adjust the priority of
video x in the feed but it's probably
going to be much more complicated than
that so this is
this is the stuff you don't see we can
see like the bands of the new york post
we can see these high profile bands
we don't see the this like very subtle
manipulation that's going on behind the
scenes pinpointing exactly
what your beliefs are and tailoring the
content
to those people they used to do that as
you say just you know based on how
interested you are in a certain topic
that's what would drive the algorithm
but it's gotten much more much more
specific than that and much more focused
on changing people's opinions this is
like their attempted brainwashing will
now work on autism another question now
here's the best part
remember that these people think anyone
to the uh was anyone to the right of
stalin
is far right yep so what they're doing
is you've got like a regular you've got
a working-class dad who's like
firing up the girl and having a burger
and they're like oh that far right guy
he's a white supremacist
better feed him content to make him a
centrist yeah we've got to be centrist
bernie sanders send him the
depolarization video immediately and
also when you have the right
and the left and the left goes way over
here now the center
is here which was further left than it
used to be the normal lefties
so they're dragging people way they're
trying to like almost
radicalize people on the right so that
they're now in literally
what they're doing yeah it's literally
what they're doing they're radicalizing
people
and that's why you see a video of these
women screaming the top of their lungs
crying and like
these are you know look there are a lot
of us i think the people who are
watching this for the most part
you have sought out information it's the
big difference between those who watch
the mainstream media and get wrapped up
in the fake news
and the people who watch shows like this
you have to you have to search for my
show
sometimes youtube youtube does recommend
certain the clips we do every day
but like i mentioned my f my main two
channels tim cast and tim cast news are
not on google google has banned them i
heard that they were
back now they are not sure they found
them nope these are these people don't
get it like
people will steal my content and
re-upload it knowing i've been
blacklisted and they can get my views
from google search we've got to
unblacklist tim's channels can't can't
do it they
google knows google knows i know and
i've complained about the google they're
doing it on purpose
normal stuff they they do it on purpose
and that's that's part of the
manipulation
if someone says did you hear you know uh
joe biden's this email thing you will
not find my videos giving you the
breakdown and the fact checks
doesn't exist this is another area where
we've actually
literally caught them red-handed so back
in uh
early 2019 i got a leak from a google
insider
and he literally called this leak the
smoking gun proving
google's bias obviously lawmakers did
nothing about it because you know we
don't have enough smoking guns
this was youtube's controversial search
query blacklist
it's an actual list they have inside
youtube with a list of so-called
controversial search queries
and whenever they add a term to that
list what it does is it tells the
algorithm to prioritize all the videos
from the mainstream media
and shut out anyone that doesn't meet
youtube standards meets youtube's
approval and i don't
and uh the reason i found out about this
list was because a left-wing journalist
had reached out to google saying look at
all these pro-life videos in the top 10
search results for abortion
and within hours google goes in
they alter that file they reorder the
search results completely do you know
the name of that journalist
i was a slate journalist if i recall
like i remember exactly and i'm pretty
sure she's the one who got who got
enrique tario banned from chase bank
all right there are these journalists
who make a profession out of d
platforming this is this is
this is what they do so they'll send a
message which is a veiled threat
to a corporation right so let's say you
know alum
ellen's nachos is a company and i see
a proud boy eating them i send a message
saying
i couldn't help but notice that the
proud boys were eating your nachos
do you support white supremacy and why
do you support white supremacy
and they immediately respond with we
hereby disavow we want nothing and then
the journalist puts out a message nacho
chip company disavows the proud boys and
this is what they did to pewdiepie right
this is the model you reach out to
everyone's business partners everyone
who's doing business with them anyone's
giving them a service and you you use
loaded questions
kind of like uh uh what what are some of
these jokes
you say uh when did you stop beating
your wife
right it's like wait wait hold on it's a
loaded question like you have to the
assumption is
right so that what they'll do is they'll
reach out to your business partner to
your
your partners and it's almost like
tortious interference they will
ask a loaded question now many of these
companies they get this email and it'll
say
we saw the proud boys wearing your shirt
fred perry
why do you support white supremacy and
there's they they know there's nothing
they can do
the company knows that it's it's total
bs
but they're going to get a pr hit unless
they play ball
they don't care about you so they just
say send them the generic response we
hereby disavow all of that
and then boom so i talked to people i
was talking to these guys recently and
they wanted to get like a photograph and
stuff and i said i'm not interested in
doing photos
with with other companies and i was like
because of the political ramifications
and they're like no no no trust me these
companies don't care and i said no no
you don't understand
when the company ends up getting
inundated by anti-fun the far left
and then not caring about me issues some
stupid statement insulting and defaming
me then i have to deal with them
not the wacko far left if i if i if i'm
seen in a photograph or
you know not i don't think i have to
worry about this too much but if there's
somebody
who is seen in a photograph with say
coke a coca-cola executive
then coke gonna be like we don't know
who this guy is or care disavow and
they'll put out a statement saying white
supremacy is wrong and we hereby disable
this individual
thus creating a newspaper story calling
you a white supremacist
that's the tactic the far left uses
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you